How I Met Your Mother how'd you feel
about the show love the show you loved
the show and you loved the cast love the
show love the cast our director Pam
Fryman directed every episode she was
fantastic uh loved the character loved
like I got to wear suits and and be like
this Super Macho alpha male guy it was
just a great role so and it was great
too cuz it revive I don't want to say
revived your career it wasn't like you
died and you know got away but but it
was kind of the trajectory was doie
Hower yeah you could do some Lifetime
movies but then you did Harold and Kumar
har Kumar which is a dumb Stoner film
yeah but Harold and Kumar who saw you in
Harold and Kumar and thought of you for
um uh what did they think of you for for
the for the for the show on CBS right
yeah I guess so yeah I think Carter and
Craig who were who wrote how I at your
mother had seen Harold and Kumar and
thought that my H quotient was higher
than it had been previously maybe I
don't know it made you hip cuz you were
in a stoner mov I think so a little bit
and you think that's how How I Met Your
Mother came about didn't hurt right and
and How I Met Your Mother I thought you
would have made more money on that show
you made $250,000 an episode when it
ended how do you know that cuz I know it
I I know everything we we were we were
well paid by the end for sure are were
you happy with what you were paid on
that show are you kidding am my humble
estimation
$250,000 a week wait a second yes I was
happy with any normal situation that
sounds extraordinary except in Show
Business where if you're the main guy
which I think you became the draw on
that show if may say so do you think so
well I think Barney was a kind of a
breakout role character but I don't it
certainly was a proper Ensemble for the
entire run of the thing it's not like it
spun towards Barney does everyone make
$250,000 a week by the end yeah everyone
made the same they did and do you how do
you know that how do you know somebody
isn't getting paid more uh because
that's said weird like weird nasty
negotiation times when all of a sudden
it's season four 4 to 5 and it's time to
like see now we're in syndication so
everyone starts asking for more money
and everyone gathers together internally
and decides do we want to go
individually and try and do our make our
own deals or do we want to go unified as
a cast and all go together and isn't it
weird when you have a cast like How I
Met Your Mother and there's you know
five of you who want to go in together
and there's like one hold out who says
you know [__] you guys I think I can do
better on my own it it it could break up
an ensemble test right yeah yeah why do
you laugh because that happened didn't
it uh no not exactly that way but I
certainly I was more in the latter Camp
than the former Camp so the [__] was
you I wasn't an [__] I just felt like
it it seemed like we all had individual
careers that we had nurtured up into
that point and so when you end up with
an agent and a manager and an attorney
that you've like you have relationships
with them and they're hardcore fighting
for you financially for your future that
that that to have solidarity with
someone who has done less or has you
know they benefit from sort of brought
up by your understood but it's a you
know you know CBS and you know how the
the industry of television and the
Hollywood works is your work you know
you're fighting for yourself and your
take within it so it wasn't like I was
trying to take someone else's money I
just wanted my team to fight as hard as
they could for me for my next season's
work why did you go and eventually uh uh
go in with all of them and come up to
the same level well because we got eight
seasons out of it we were we were about
to not have a ninth season
um and then we all sort of got together
and said this was not my doing this was
just like an extra season like a
fantastic final lap and why shouldn't
everyone reap the benefits of that by
season 9 I feel like everyone has proven
their worth on the show everyone is
providing and and deserves to get paid
well